I think your mothers are going to be in
for some criticism they are prominently
featured in this documentary just kid
things they were just doing kid things
he just came across as a loving caring
kind sone and I think as most mothers
looking at this they think what was
wrong with him how could they have
allowed it why did they allow it and
your answer do you feel your mothers
need to be defended are you are you okay
with your mothers both of you My yes my
relationship with my mother has grown
immensely over the last six years or so
it was really challenging for a while
and I've gone through many phases just
in this healing process in relation to
I've gone through lots of anger towards
her lots of confusion thankfully we've
been able to go through a lot of healing
through this process because the
mother's number one job is to protect
her child and as I watched that I had a
lot of questions about how the behavior
of your mother's in particular yeah the
parents are groomed the parents are
groomed the parents are groomed as well
so it's Michael spends a lot of time
talking to your parents and connecting
with them and build relationships so
it's not they he pays attention to them
and they're groomed over the time so it
is their job to protect us and they
didn't but I try to look at it from
their point of view without letting them
up though because obviously that's their
job but they were groomed as well